from the playful to the practical to the
cubed to the honored dogs are everywhere
in America
today there are about 70 million dogs in
the United States alone one for every
four people but what is our obsession
with them and how much do we really love
them to find out we travel to see the
love firsthand doggie pampering is a big
business billions of dollars each year
are spent to keep them happy healthy and
well groomed
this is Samson and this is Delilah with
ponytails they're yorkshire terriers and
they were bred to be tiny so they're not
going to be much more than four pounds
patricia young lives in a suburb outside
washington DC they have plenty of
clothes they have almost as many clothes
as I do I can't go anywhere without
somebody stopping us I guess they're
filling my emptiness because I have
grown children and there's nobody here
so they're good company for me
they have a robes come out of the shower
in the bath they have a couple of vest
couple of jackets here they have hats
too
they also have boots which they don't
like wearing the hats on the beach it's
a little cold for that but I think this
is cute this is karate outfit since it's
so cold we'll put these on
and we're getting ready to go to old
house and we have to get dressed and
they will have to get in our little bag
so that I can take them to the car to
their car seat samson and delilah aren't
just clothes horses or dogs they also
enjoy the delights of some R&R at the
spot this is the old town pet resort in
arefox county virginia the most
luxurious largest pet resort in the
probably in the world we have a truly
dedicated staff that loves animals we
hear many customers and dog owners say
you know my dog is so happy here he
doesn't seem to want to go home because
the the dogs can play up to 12 hours a
day if they're in day camp and they get
walked three to four times a day this is
our grooming salon and state-of-the-art
and it may be nicer than a lot of your
barber shops here we have Laird ginger
biscuit and toots who are sharing a
rotunda five-star luxury suites these
guys all have television and if you
really miss your dog you can walk your
dog on the internet camera provided here
she just loves it she wants to get in
the water so bad here we have our
hydrotherapy room originally we designed
it with hip dysplasia attic and
geriatric dogs in mind but increasingly
we have a lot of labs and Golden's just
real high-energy dogs they all wear life
jackets unless
they're really talented and they've been
coming for a long time maybe this seems
indulgent and overload areas for dogs
but you know that that is how Americans
are living and the dogs sort of are
cheaper than psychotherapy and as people
in our lives come and go it's comforting
to know we'll always have someone to
play with
and call family